red rock loop is closed it has been
since earlier this morning nevada
highway patrol says one of its troopers
opened fire at the park although the
park we understand is open this
afternoon though the scene is still very
active hector mejia has the latest
this is where that closure begins where
park rangers are blocking the entrance
for the scenic loop again it's closed
right now while authorities investigate
a shooting involving nhp troopers i'm
trying to do a hike today and this
happened the shooting never should have
happened i don't know what the extent of
the details are this is it's obviously a
tragic situation and it's obviously
going to impact everybody's day like
mine
details are limited at this hour metro
police saying they are handling the
investigation we know it happened just
before six o'clock this morning the
scenic loop is closed the shooting
involves nevada highway patrol we do not
know who was hit or the extent of the
injuries or anything surrounding the
circumstances we are waiting for a
briefing from nevada highway patrol and
we are working for more information
we'll make sure to let you know as soon
as we learn more reporting at red rock
hector mejia live local now